una amarga Liberación seguida del
destierro la justicia nicaragüense
escarceló sin previa aviso a 222 presos
políticos opositores críticos disidentes
sandinistas Defensores de derechos
humanos y estudiantes detenidos por
supuestamente desafiar al régimen
autoritario de Daniel Ortega los
deportado fueron declarados traidores a
la patria y sancionados por diferentes
delitos graves
e inhabilitados de forma perpetua para
ejercer la función pública En nombre del
Servicio del Estado de Nicaragua así
como ejercer cargos de elección popular
entonces escarcelados deportados a
Estados Unidos desde la prisión de la
modelo se enteraron a las puertas de
subir al avión de su expulsión siendo
también despojados de sus derechos Como
ciudadanos nicaragüenses en el país
norteamericano familiares y amigos
esperaban su llegada muy aferrada a la
esperanza de que un día va a ser libre y
eso cualquiera con una dictadura podría
agachar la cabeza y ella siempre se
mantuvo muy positiva y muy fuerte
Washington elogió la liberación y
sostuvo que fue una decisión unilateral
del régimen de Ortega acogemos con
satisfacción la oportunidad de ofrecer
esta protección humanitaria a estos
presos políticos mientras que la
organización de los Estados Americanos
exigió a Nicaragua restituir los
derechos de los presos políticos en
Nicaragua todavía hay personas
encarceladas y torturadas por pensar
diferente todavía hay personas que viven
a diario con el temor de ser detenidas
juzgadas Y sentenciadas sin ninguna
garantía legal ni procesal según el
mecanismo de presas y presos políticos
de Nicaragua un observatorio civil
todavía quedan 38 presos políticos en
las cárceles del país centroamericano